oh hey TV people I'm mark Normand monk
Normand is a stand-up comedian and he's
very good at what he does please welcome
mark Normand people I say we mark gotta
be more confident then they say mark
gotta be yourself I'm like you got to
pick one when it comes to making people
laugh mark Norman's knows exactly what
he's doing
however when it comes to everything else
in Mark's life mark Berman sex mark
Normand sucks at everything on the moon
mercury mini tub mark Normand needs help
for example these are just some of the
things that every 35 year old adult
should be able to do a mark can't figure
out how to do any of them is right I
can't but there is some good news we'll
let Stephen Hawking explain there are an
infinite number of universes and each
one of those infinite universes contains
an infinite number of realities that can
only mean one thing there are an
infinite number of different mark
Norman's out there in the multiverse who
are completely embarrassed by this loser
and motivated to help him finally get
each week on mark Normand needs help
mark Normand lives his life as a
comedian in New York City and each week
he'll encounter a situation that he is
simply not prepared for you've never
been to a bris before having been mark
you're gonna love it man that's when one
of the infinite number of mark Norman's
shows up to teach this poor guy exactly
what he needs to do don't look right at
it and in ten minutes we get to stuff
our face with bagels and lox don't look
at the baby's dick we get to eat
[Applause]
confused okay stay with me let's say
mark Normand was going to pitch a
television show mark your agent tells me
you have a great idea all right all
right it's about me I'm clueless I'm a
big [__] [__] that's your show thank
you so much for coming in mark it's
great - great to see you long before it
gone - this a different version of mark
Normand from an alternate universe who
knows exactly how to handle this
specific situation would appear to save
our boys skin we have a four-quadrant
appeal and that's fans across all gender
racial and sexual identities you know
we've got four quadrant appeal let's go
straight to series on this thing no
matter the issue Mark's got a guardian
angel from another dimension there to
help him and teach us one story a week
lots of laughs and plenty of important
information how is that I just got some
pointers for my alternate version of
myself from another universe
felis mark Normand needs help a high
concept comedy about a low functioning
comedian I think he means me
[Music]